ja und zum tagesgespräch ist jetzt im
studio ich freue mich darüber der
fraktionsvorsitzende der partei die
linke gregor gysi
ich würde gerne mit gestern anfang
gregor gysi 25.000 menschen waren in
dresden knapp 5000 waren in leipzig um
innerhalb der pdl und lega bewegung für
ihre interessen zu demonstrieren sie
selber haben gesagt das ist auch zum
teil jeden fall so habe ich das
verstanden ein problem ostdeutscher
mentalität zumindest bei den älteren
könnten sie uns das bitte noch mal etwas
näher erklären wie sie das mal eine ging
es darum zu erklären wie welche ängste
entstanden sind bei menschen und das ist
eine gemeinsame aufgabe ist von kirchen
gewerkschaften politik wissenschaft
kultur die bisher vernachlässigt wurde
solche ängste abzubauen ich meine ich
die anführer verstehen sie diesen
verkorkster braucht man nichts mehr zu
machen
aber die da mitlaufen und ängste sind
dass es für mich so erstaunlich immer
abstrakt rechte werden nie dort gewählt
vor drücke ich viele ausländerinnen und
ausländer leben sondern immer dort
gewählt wo es kaum welche gibt und diese
abstrakten ängste da habe ich nur mal
darauf hingewiesen dass zettel der erne
geschlossene gesellschaft war und somit
einem stoß wurden wir ja nicht nur
deutsche sondern europäer weltbürger
alles mögliche und das war vielleicht
für einige auch eine
überforderungssituation aber gestern
muss ich ihnen sagen das war nur ein tag
meines erachtens wo sich bewiesen hat
p&g da ist nicht das volk sondern das
gegenteil davon
denn zum beispiel diese großen
demonstrationszüge die sie gerade
gezeigt haben dagegen in leipzig und in
vielen anderen städten haben ja bewiesen
dass die gegner von p&g da weit
überwiegen und das hat mich ehrlich
gesagt sogar recht warum sind die
anführer von tiger wie sie selber sagen
verkorkst aus ihrer sicht was ist davon
zu wissen
das ist immer diejenigen die sich das
ideologisch als konzept legen die sind
nicht mehr davon weg zu bringen dass
meine erfahrung weil nicht mit
rechtsextremistischen jugendlichen ist
wieder was anderes spreche so ist 14 15
16 jahren da gebe ich die hoffnung noch
nicht auf dass man sie zur vernunft
bringen kann
an mitteln funktionieren das könnte
bleiben lassen dann sogar keine chance
an die kommen sie nicht rein
und deshalb sage ich immer die anführer
die haben
ihre ziele die haben ihre taktik die am
ihre strategie aber die die einfach
mitlaufen also wenn sie wollen bin ich
gerne zum gespräch bereit gibt
allerdings auch noch auseinandersetzung
weil sie wissen wem sie hinterher laufen
das muss man ihnen auch ganz klar sagen
und auch vorwerfen wenn jetzt einer der
bei peggy damit läuft sagt meine rente
ist so klein ich kann kaum davon leben
und die flüchtlinge den wird ein gutes
flüchtlingsheim gestellt was würden sie
denn dann antworten das ist ja eines der
klassischen organe dorthin würde ich
folgendes erklären das ist ein grosser
irrtum zu glauben dass man armut dadurch
abbaut dass es weniger arme gibt wie
kommt er überhaupt darauf dass seine
rente erhöht wird wenn es keine
flüchtlinge mehr gäbe vielleicht werden
meine diäten erhöht aber nicht seine
rente
so ist auch unsere gesellschaft
gestrickt dieser blick zur seite und
nach unten ist völlig falsch
man muss nach oben blicken wenn wir das
verhältnis zwischen reichtum und armut
nicht verändern werden wir armut nicht
beseitigen deshalb ärgert es mich ja das
rechte rechtsextreme leute vor allen
dingen immer das ausnutzen und sagen es
gibt zu viele arme wenn es weniger arme
gebe hätten die anderen am meer das ist
blödsinn
das ist einfach quatsch so ist unsere
gesellschaft überhaupt nicht
strukturiert das würde ich ihm sein
vielleicht etwas freundlicher vielleicht
auch nicht je nachdem wie er mich fragt
wahrscheinlich engagiert ich habe auch
ein bisschen selbstkritik raus gelesen
sie haben gesagt wir die politische
klasse nicht nur die anderen parteien
auch wie die linken haben etwas versäumt
nämlich ängste vor dem islam rechtzeitig
zu erkennen und dagegen an zu arbeiten
wie kann man dagegen anarbeiten also
abbauen muss man sehen
das heißt wir brauchen in erster linie
aufklärung wir brauchen aufklärung in
der schule wir brauchen aufklärung in
anderen bildungseinrichtungen in der
kultur in der wissenschaft in den medien
überall und deshalb habe ich angeregt
dass ich mal alle fraktionsvorsitzenden
und die vize-präsidentin und der
präsident des bundestages zusammen
setzen und sich überlegen wie können wir
so was hinbekommen noch mit kirchen mit
gewerkschaften mit kultur und
wissenschaft dass wir eben sagen so
jetzt starten wir mal eine
aufklärungskampagne die kostet ja auch
ein bisschen geld da braucht man auch
ein paar leute darüber müssten wir
vorschläge unterbreiten denn wir dürfen
uns versäumnisse auf dieser strecke
dürfen wir uns gar nicht leisten und ich
nehme mich da auch gar nicht aus wir
haben alle diesbezüglich zu wenig getan
nur mit geld global kommt nicht anders
ich sag ja nur so kostet ein bisschen
was versehen
das bereitstellen um wirklich aufklärung
zu machen ängste abzubauen
ich sagte ihnen ein beispiel es gab
demonstrationen gegen eine moschee ich
habe auch mit demonstranten gesprochen
in pankow jetzt steht die moschee ist
eine ganz friedliche gemeinde es gibt
nicht mehr die geringsten
auseinandersetzung also wenn es denn da
ist plötzlich und das ganze ist
widerlegt dann ist es gut
ergo kann ich mit solchen beispielen
operieren und versuchen den menschen zu
erklären dass ihre ängste unbegründet so
debatte gehören aber immer mindestens
zwei seiten
es gibt stimmungen hier bei uns ich
nehme sie so war wenn man viel ließ dann
kann man das woraus interpretieren so
gesagt wird die muslime selbst haben zu
wenig getan um selber auch zu zeigen
dass sie sich abgrenzen von jeder form
der gewalt und dass sie sich auch mehr
einbringen wollen in das was ich immer
sage verfassungs patriotisch was hier
deutschland als rechtsstaat darstellt
können sie den folgen das mag für
einzelne zu treffen es gibt jetzt sogar
eine selbstkritik von verbänden die
gesagt haben wir haben die salafisten
und sowas unterschätzt wir werden uns
jetzt ganz anders damit
auseinandersetzen
heute die mahnwache ist ja organisiert
von von den muslimischen verbänden die
erstens für toleranz und zweitens strikt
gegen diese verbrechen die er begangen
worden sind in frankreich und ich sag ja
wir alle können uns noch diesbezüglich
verbessern
auch dort kann man sich überlegen wie
können wir mehr aufklärung machen und
anderes mehr
nur ich sag auch die verbände haben es
ja auch nicht leicht da gab es ein
treffen mit dem bundesinnenminister
nicht nur um sicherheitsfragen
es war nach islamkonferenz richtig
richtig die soll sich jetzt nur ein
bisschen ändern das hoffe ich damit wir
auch uns überlegen wie kann man denn
unterschiedliche kulturen zusammenfügen
wie können wir einen anderen respekt
haben wir dürfen doch unsere kultur
nicht anderen aufzwingen die natürlich
auch nicht uns ergo muss man doch für
eine andere form von toleranz eintreten
und so weiter aber ich meine kern sehen
wir uns doch mit der ganz großen
mehrheit aller muslimen gläubigen
menschen einig dass gewalt ein völlig
falsches instrument es nur wenn wir den
terrorismus wirksam bekämpfen wollen
dann muss man eben begreifen dass so was
wie der afghanistan krieg völlig
falsches denn erzeugt neuen hass und
nicht weniger sondern mehr terrorismus
mittels krieg terrorismus niemals
wirksam bekämpfen im gegenteil man
erzeugt nur die breite
schafft zu neuem terrorismus was
brauchen wir am dringendsten in der
debatte jetzt es gibt die
gesellschaftliche debatte die wir gerade
auch versucht haben ein bisschen
anzureißen wie sie vielleicht geführt
werden könnte wir können auch politische
maßnahmen ergreifen wird ja im moment
diskutiert ein einwanderungsgesetz wird
diskutiert möglicherweise dass es kommen
soll dass es nötig ist verschärfung des
asylrechts fällt mir da rein auf der
sicherheit seite vorratsdatenspeicherung
personalausweise die für die
personalausweise die von
ausreisewilligen extremisten nach syrien
ausreisewilligen möglicherweise länger
eingezogen werden als bisher
das sind alles antworten auf der
politischen ebene was halten sie davon
also bei einem einwanderungsgesetz
wissen sie stört mich eine formulierung
die ich immer wieder höre dass es werden
sterben jedes jahr mehr deutsche als
deutsche geboren werden vielleicht
müsste man mal darüber nachdenken eine
kinderfreundlichere gesellschaft zu
werden ich spreche mal von kitas schulen
vielem anderen aber abgesehen davon wird
mir dann immer gesagt ja wir müssen
jetzt fachleute aus der dritten welt
holen könnte sein dass die dritte welt
vielleicht ihre fachleute selbst braucht
ist das fair wenn wir mit mehr geld
locken und denen die ihre fachleute
entziehen mache ich mal ein großes
fragezeichen sie möchten sie in einem
einwanderungsgesetz tschuldigung dass
ich unterbreche nicht steuern und sagen
wir können qualitätskriterien erstellen
also dass wir sagen der ja der nein wenn
die kriterien erfüllt sind einer lok ein
bisschen zu kanada oder den usa
wenn wir elend hunger überwinden wollen
wenn wir überwinden wollen dass die
dritte welt so nachhinkt in vielen
fragen dann dürfen wir nicht eine
struktur aufbauen wo wir sagen das beste
von dort holen wir uns und dann sollen
sie sehen wie sie zurechtkommen
dann kriegen wir die antwort in form von
flüchtlingen dann kriegen wir päda
erzählte also mit anderen worten wir
müssen hier einen anderen weg gehen
das zweite ist wir haben ja im kern
sicherheitsgesetze das schauen wir uns
an ich freue mich dass justizminister
gesagt hat die vorratsdatenspeicherung
kommt für ihn nicht in frage die bringt
doch gar nicht wissen wir dieses gejagt
nach information nach daten und dann was
hat es genutzt in frankreich wieder mich
also ich glaube wir müssen eine andere
strategie gehen aber immer wenn so etwas
passiert kommen sofort rufen neu
gesetzte neue gesetze und in der regel
bringen sie nicht übrigens gibt es immer
noch gesetze die uns behindern aus einer
zeit die auch wieder aus solchen
vorfällen
entstanden sind ich sage wenn der
justizministeriums gesetzesvorschläge
gemacht schon ganz in ruhe an wenn sie
vernünftig sind wenn wir sie
unterstützen wenn sie nicht vernünftig
sind werden wir halt die opposition sein
wie zb hat den sie hatten zu machen
selbstverständlich das war gregor gysi
fraktionsvorsitzender der linken im
deutschen bundestag
vielen dank